ORIGIN BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ DALLY DODD THE RAZA.
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ. ROSE
ERTZ HUESO HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LEHRER. LEYVA WHAT
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
TOTAL OF. HEY TWENTYNINE ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER NUMBER WHITE
HOUSE STEVE WIENER WELL.
MEMBERS ARE QUORUM IS. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND ARE BE THE ROOM AND
IN THE PLAY DRAW THE DAY WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER BY CENTER.
AFTER WHICH REMAIN STAND THERE
WILL BE INTO OF BY CENTER
HERTZBERG. MEMBERS AS WE SELL
EARTH DAY TODAY LET US PRAY
THIS PRAYER OF HOPE FOR FROM
THE LOUD SI. ALL POWERFUL GOD.
YOU ARE PRESENT IN THE WHOLE
UNIVERSE IN THE SMALLEST OF
YOUR CREATURES. YOU EMBRACE
WITH YOUR TENDERNESS ALL THAT
EXISTS. POUR OUT UPON US THE
POWER OF YOUR LOVE THAT WE MAY
PROTECT LIFE AND BEAUTY. FILL
US WITH PEACE THAT WE MAY LIVE
AS BROTHERS AND SISTERS HARMING
NO ONE. WELL GOD OF THE POOR
HELP US TO REDUCE RESCUE THE
ABANDONED FORGOTTEN OF THIS
EARTH SO PRECIOUS IN YOUR EYES.
BRING HEALING TO OUR LIVES THAT
WE MAY PROTECT THE WORLD AND
NOT PREY UPON IT. THAT WE ME SO
BEAUTY NOT POLLUTION AND
DESTRUCTION. TOUCH THE HEARTS
OF THOSE WHO LOOK ONLY FOR GAIN
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE POOR. AND
THE EARTH. TEACHERS TO DISCOVER
THE WORTH OF EACH THING TO BE
FILLED WITH AWE AND
CONTEMPLATION TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE ARE PROFOUNDLY UNITED WITH
EVERY CREATURE AS WE JOURNEY
TOWARD. YOUR INFINITE LIGHT. WE
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
EACH DAY ENCOURAGE US WE PRAY
IN OUR STRUGGLE. FOR JUSTICE
LOVE AND PEACE. AND LET US SAY
I MEANT. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. SO. ALL. MEMBERS
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE CENTERS
ON MON AND SENATOR STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS AROUND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. ARE
THERE ANY. CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE UP SENATE
THIRD READING FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE SB FIFTY SEVEN CENTER
WIENER YOU PREPARE. RENDON
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
WIENER AN ACT RELATING TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. WIENER I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT BECAUSE
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIFTY SEVEN. WHICH WILL
HELP US TO ADDRESS THE ONGOING
EPIDEMIC OF DRUG OVERDOSES IN
CALIFORNIA BY ALLOWING BUT NOT
REQUIRING- THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE CITY OF
OAKLAND. TO HAVE THE DISCRETION
TO AUTHORIZE OVERDOSE
AS SAFE CONSUMPTION SITES.
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE PROGRAMS WHERE PEOPLE MAY
USE THEIR OWN CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF STAFF TRAINED TO
PREVENT AND TO TREAT OVERDOSE
IS. TO PREVENT HIV AND
HEPATITIS INFECTION AND TO
FACILITATE ENTRY INTO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT AND
OTHER SERVICES. OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE
NECESSARY INTERVENTION TO
PREVENT OVERDOSE DEATHS.
ASSEMBLY ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY OF THESE PROGRAMS
EXISTED IN TEN COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD AND THEY HAVE BEEN
RIGOROUSLY RESEARCHED AND SHOWN
TO REDUCE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG
USE INCLUDING A REDUCTION IN
PUBLIC DRUG USE. BY MOVING
PEOPLE INSIDE TO A CLEAN AND
SAFE AND HEALTHY SPACE FOR THE
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF INJECTING OR
USING ON SIDEWALKS OR IN PARKS
OR IN FRONT OF PEOPLE'S HOMES
OR BUSINESSES CAN USE INSIDE.
BY REDUCING SYRINGE LITTER. BY
REDUCING HIV AND HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
BY REDUCING OVERDOSE DEATHS. IN
THE MANY YEARS THAT THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
AROUND THE WORLD A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY OF THEM THERE HAS NEVER
NOT ONCE IN A RECORDED OVERDOSE
DEATHS IN ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES NOT A SINGLE
OVERDOSE STAFF. THESE PROGRAMS
RESULT IN A REDUCTION IN ER
VISITS AND PARAMEDIC CALLS.
WHICH WE KNOW NOW DURING
COALBED THAT'S A GOOD THING TO
REDUCE STRESS ON OUR HOSPITALS.
THEY DON'T INCREASE CRIME. AND
THEY DO INCREASE ENTRY INTO
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. AND THAT IS
WHY ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN
ADDICTION TREATMENT TO GET
PEOPLE HEALTHY ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. KHALIS CALIFORNIA
OUR NATION ARE IN THE MIDST OF
AN UNPRECEDENTED EXPLOSION OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS IT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS ALMOST FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES DIED OF OVERDOSE DEATHS
LAST YEAR. WE'RE SEEING RECORDS
IN SAN FRANCISCO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AROUND THE STATE
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS NOT WORKING
AND WE NEED TO TRY A PROVEN
TOOL THAT HAS WORKED AROUND THE
WORLD. THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
DRUG TREATMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES AND IS
SUPPORTED BY NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS SPECIALIZING IN
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT. SB
FIFTY SEVEN PROVIDES CALIFORNIA
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD BY
EXAMPLE. AND TO HELP ADDRESS
THIS TERRIBLE EPIDEMIC OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. C. NINE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BACKER. FIVE FOUR. NO
BRADFORD HI CUPBEARER. CORTESE
FIVE DALLY NO DODD HI TO RAZA I
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO
HI FURTADO. JONES. NO KAMLAGER
I LAYERED HI LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
HI MELENDEZ NO MAN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN NO A CHAU VOGUE. NO HAN
AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER I WILL. NOW
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
UP TO MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
CABALLERO. GLAZER NO HER TADO
NO NEWMAN. PORTANTINO. RUBIO
AMBERG. FIVE TWENTY ONE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS NOW WERE MOVING BACK TO
THE SENATE OUR READING. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS OF SIX THIRTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY NINE SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SEVENTY TWO. FIVE
TO SIX FIFTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE TWENTY THREE
SECOND READING FILE DE MARIA.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR. MAN PROTIUM SHE'S
PREPARED. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
SENATORS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR I RISE
TODAY TO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR THIS NOMINATION THE RULES
COMMITTEE REVIEWED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VONTAZE APPOINTMENT
YESTERDAY AND APPROVED SENDING
HIS NOMINATION TO THE FLOOR.
THE HEARING YESTERDAY CONFIRMED
FOR ME THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA WILL BRING HIS PASSION
FOR JUSTICE AND HIS CONCERN
ABOUT PEOPLE TO EVERY ASPECT OF
THIS IMPORTANT JOB. RECENTLY IN
TALKING ABOUT THE SENATE'S BILL
BACK BOLDLY BUDGET PROPOSAL I
FOCUSED ON THE POINT THAT WE
HAVE A ONCE IN A GENERATION
CHANCE TO MAKE TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
BELIEVE THAT CAN HAPPEN ACROSS
THE BOARD NOT JUST IN HOW WE
MAKE INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET.
BUT ANYHOW WE ENACT JUST LAWS
AND HOW WE CHANGE THE CULTURE
AND THAT INCLUDES MAKING OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM MORE
RESPONSIBLE. MORE RESPONSIVE
AND MORE REPRESENTATIVE. TO
COLLEAGUES AFTER YESTERDAY'S
HEARING AND OUR YEARS OF
SERVICE TOGETHER I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR TACKLING THOSE
CHALLENGES. WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR EYES AND- THANK YOU
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. CENTER PAN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SAND SENATORS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'M
PROUD TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT ROB BONTA
TO BE OUR NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AS A MEMBER BONTA IS SAY- BOTH
THE CAUCUS COLLEAGUE AND FORMER
CHAIR OF. OUR CAUCUS IS LEGAL
LEGISLATIVE AND LIVED
EXPERIENCE MAKES HIM THE
SUPERIOR CHOICE TO REPRESENT
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE. MR
BONTA HOLDS A LAW DEGREE FROM
YALE LAW SCHOOL HAS NEARLY
FIFTEEN YEARS OF LITIGATION
EXPERIENCE IN BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTOR AND TWENTY
TWELVE ROB BONTA BECAME THE
FIRST FILIPINO AMERICAN TO
SERVE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND IF CONFIRMED TODAY WILL BE
THE FIRST FILIPINO AMERICAN AND
ONLY THE SECOND ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER TO BE CALIFORNIA'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AS A
LEGISLATOR WE HAVE WITNESSED
HIS LEADERSHIP DISEASE AUTHORED
LEGISLATION CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY. AND MANY
OTHER AREAS. FROM HIS EARLY
CHILDHOOD SOME NEVER BONTA WAS
EXPOSED TO THE FARMWORKER LABOR
MOVEMENT WORST PARENTS WORKED
AS FARM WORKER ORGANIZERS. HIS
LIFE HAS BEEN SHAPED BY SERVICE
INTEGRITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
IS EXTREMELY QUALIFIED WOULD
REPRESENT THE BEST OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP. ECKLEY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN
CONFIRMING ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB
BONTA AS OUR NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AYE
RISES VERY STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE CONFIRMATION OF ROB BONTA
FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS VERY
DISTINGUISHED CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE HE HAS CHAMPIONED
CRITICAL LEGISLATION HIS WORK
TO EMPOWER ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
TO PROTECT THE SPECIALLY. THE
RIGHTS OF OUR VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS HIS FOCUS MUCH OF HIS
TIME AND ATTENTION ON HOW OUR
STATE CAN FIX SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICES WHAT WHETHER IT'S
BIG POLLUTERS A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM CONSUMERS OR
DEFENDING OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
THE FORCES OF HATE. LIKE OUR
STATE'S MOST RECENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S JERRY BROWN KAMALA
HARRIS AND HAVE YET BEEN SET UP
I'M CONFIDENT MR BONTA WILL
SERVE WITH DISTINCTION AND
PURPOSE HE ALWAYS FOUGHT FOR
JUSTICE IN THE INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH HIM IN THE
YEARS TO COME ON BOLD AND
PROGRESSIVE PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES THAT ADVANCE JUSTICE
PROMOTE EQUITY AND ENHANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRIME- I RISE
THERE'S KAKA CHAIR OF THE READ
CAUCUSES MORNING TO SHARE OF
JUST A THOUGHT. ON THIS
CONFIRMATION- WE WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA IS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
CHALLENGES BEFORE HIM- ARM AND-
HAMMER LEE INTENDS TO ADDRESS
THOSE. HOWEVER WE ARE STILL-
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED REGARDING
ALL OF HIS PAST RECORDS A
HUNDRED NO HE- TO VERY STRONGLY
TO BOTH OF US AND RULES AND ON
CALLS WITH A NUMBER OF OUR
MEMBERS. IT IS VERY COMMITTED
TO A BIPARTISAN RULE- ON ISSUES
THAT DO AFFECT OUR CONSTITUENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS MORNING WE
WILL NOT BE IN SUPPORT BUT DO
YOU WANT TO RECOGNIZE ON A
COMMITMENT AND A PASSION THAT
HE WILL BRING TO THIS SONG. TO
THIS ASSIGNMENT AND WE WISH HIM
WELL AND WE LOOK VERY MUCH
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
IN THE COMING YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU. MR PRESIDENT AND ARE RIGHT
SOME OF THE ARAKAN. OF A MEMBER
ROB BONTA FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL
OUR DISTRICTS OVERLAP AND WE
HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE AND GOOD
FORTUNE TO WORK TOGETHER NOW
FOR SINCE THE POINT THAT HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY AND-
TWENTY. TO TURN NOW I'M GONNA
FORGET TWENTY JENNER TWENTY
TWELVE ANYWAY- TWENTY TWELVE-
AND WE WERE FACING A- REALLY
CRITICAL. I WOULDN'T SAY NO
EXACT GREAT THIS MOMENT IN THE
LONG COUPLE OF YEARS A VERY
STRONG EXAMINER. OUR JUSTICE.
AND WHAT IT REALLY TRULY JUST.
AND THEN WHAT IT'S IN HAVE BEEN.
ONE OR LOW INCOME. AND A
SPECIAL OUR CAN OF. DAN THIS
ARE WHAT JUST. HAS PASSED
NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT REFORM.
THAT THE AG THE TO OF JUSTICE
THE AG'S OFFICE WILL HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT.
AND WE HAVE ALSO PASSED A
NUMBER OF REFORMS THAT. WE PUT
A FOCUS TRUE TO. UNDERSTAND AND-
JUST THROUGH THE LENS OF RACIAL
EQUITY. AND WHILE THERE COULD
BE MANY POSSIBLE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
TAKE ON THAT MANTLE AND HELP US
IN REALLY RE LOOKING AT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM THROUGH THAT
LENS I THINK THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED FOR THAT ANDI ALSO
THINK THAT WE BENEFIT FROM THE
FACT THAT HE WAS THE MOST
SERVED IN THE LAST A- PERIOD OF
TIME OVER A DECADE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SO HE HAS BEEN A
PARTNER WITH US. IN REALLY
TACKLING AND TAKE ON TRYING
UNDER. BETTER THOSE ISSUES AND
ADDITIONALLY THE ISSUES OF.
POLICE VIOLENCE. AND THERE IS A
VERY. BILL THAT THE DOJ IS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT IS GOING
TO SET UP AN INDEPENDENT
INDEPENDENT MEANING THROUGH THE
DOJ OFFICE SO. ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE THE SHOOTINGS THAT
RESULT IN THE DEATH OF AN
UNARMED CIVILIANS AND WE HAVE
NOT HAD THAT IN CALIFORNIA SO
THERE ARE SOME VERY UNIQUE-
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE EXPECT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NOW
TO TAKE ON BANDS I THINK AGAIN
THAT WE HAVE A PERSON AS
UNIQUELY SUITED FOR THAT AND IT
HAS. WITH BASS OVER THE LAST
DAY REALLY SHOULD REALLY
GRAPPLED WITH THOSE ISSUES AND
I WHAT ALL OF US AND I MEAN THE
ENTIRE STATE CALIFORNIA. REEKS
THE END BETTER ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT TO RACIAL JUSTICEAND WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR. US FOR HIS
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR WARNER.
THANK YOU WITH PRESIDENT RISING
SUPPORT OF ROB BONTA I WAS
GONNA COME ATTORNEY I KNOWN-
SUMMER FROM TWENTY YEARS BACK
TO THE WHERE WE WERE CALLING-
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY IT'S
OFFICE AND WORKED ON THE SAME
TEAM- AND WORK TOGETHER EVERY
SINGLE DAY BEFORE EITHER OF US
IS AN ELECTED OFFICE- AND THE
ROB BONTA THAT I KNOW BOTH AS
AN ATTORNEY MY COLLEAGUE AND
NOW- FOR YEARS AS A COG IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS SOMEONE WHO
FIRST. WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD-
IS INCREDIBLY COLLABORATIVE AND
I THINK ANYONE WHO'S WORKED
WITH HIM ON LEGISLATION KNOWS
THAT HE IS A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH- AND SOMEONE WHO TAKES A
BROAD PERSPECTIVE- WALL ALWAYS
HAVING THE MORAL COM. OF.
THEIR
SON BECAUSE HE'S EVERYONE
SOMEONE IN THE COMMUNITY- THAT
HE IS ODDS OF DOING THIS
AMAZING WORK SAWYER TONIGHT-
THANK YOU TO SENATOR CALLED.
MISTER PRESIDENT I ACTUALLY
RIGHT OF ROB BONTA A FELLOW
HELLO MEDIAN ARE CAN RESIDENTS
BUILT SOMEBODY IS SIR CALL WITH
IS A HERE AND LEAD TO. AND I
REPEAT WHAT MY COLLEAGUE. HAVE
SAID THE CALL NAY OF ROB BONTA
YESTERDAY I PART OF AN
INTERVIEW WITH HIM THAT SAT
DOWN AND ASKED HIM SOME THESE
ABOUT THE PRESSING NEEDS OF
RACIAL JUSTICE AND ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY IN BRAZIL MINORITY
LEADER. HAS INDICATED THE
COLLABORATIVE NATURE THAT ROB
BONTA BRINGS- HI HAVE QUITE A
FEW FILIPINOS IN MY- MY
DISTRICT AND THIS IS A VERY
PROUD MOMENT FOR THEM TO BUT
ROB BONTA WILL BE A GREAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL NOT JUST A
GREAT FILIPINO ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S RECORDS AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR. CALM WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I RISE
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ROB BONTA. I
TO BE OUR NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL. I DON'T WANT THIS BACK
I WANT TO ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MADE YOU KNOW ROB IS GOING TO
FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE. HE'S
GOING TO LEAD WITH INTEGRITY.
AND HE'S GONNA SEARCH FOR
CONSENSUS I KNOW THIS. BECAUSE
HE HAS ONE THAT AS A COLLEAGUE
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU KNOW
ALL IN THIS LEGISLATURE. ROB
BONTA IS ALSO YOU KNOW HOPEFUL
AND IDEALISTIC AN ASPIRATIONAL.
IN THE BILLS THAT HE HAS RUN
AND IN THE FIGHTS THATHE HAS
FOUGHT AND I THINK THOSE ARE
INCREDIBLE TRAITS THAT WE NEED
NOW MORE THAN EVER BEFORE. IN
AN ATTORNEY GENERAL. HE IS A
GOOD FATHER. HE IS A GOOD SIGN.
HE IS A GOOD HUSBAND. STRONG
INTEGRITY. AND WITH SOLID
CHARACTER. AND I DO WANT TO
ECHO THIS AMAZINGLY PROUD
MOMENT FOR THE FILIPINO
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO OFTEN
FEEL MARGINALIZED AND SILENCED
WITHIN THE API COLLECTIVE. THIS
IS THE TIME WHEN THEY'RE GOING
TO BE POPPING BOTTLES BECAUSE
THEIR SON ROB BONTA. CAN BE
WILL BE SHOULD BE THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE NOMINATION
OF MY FRIEND ROB BONTA IS OUR
NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL FILES NOT
ONLY HISTORIC NOMINATION HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA IT WOULD BE THE FIRST
FILIPINO AMERICAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL IT'S THE RIGHT CHOICE
AT THE RIGHT TIME. AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED ON THIS FOR NUMEROUS
TIMES ARE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF HATE
AND VIOLENCE. WE'VE SEEN AT THE
SAME TIME THAT OUR STATE AND
NATION ARE GRAPPLING WITH A
WIDE ARRAY OF CHALLENGES. ON
RACIAL UNREST DOMESTIC
TERRORISM. A CERTAIN GUN
VIOLENCE AND THE NEED FOR
MEANINGFUL LAW ENFORCEMENT
REFORMS. ROB BONTA IS THE RIGHT
CHOICE FOR THIS AND ALSO A
REPRESENTATION DOES MATTER ROB
HAS THE RIGHT EXPERIENCE TO
BRING THE RIGHT PERSPECTIVE TO
OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NOT
ONLY AS FAR SAYS EXCELLENT AND
REALLY UNPARALLELED LEGAL
CREDENTIALS BUT ALSO WITH HIS
LIVED EXPERIENCE AS THE SON OF.
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS WHO
WERE CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVE IN THE
MOVEMENT ROB HAS TAKEN THE
TOUGHEST ISSUES HE'S TAKEN
THOSE LESSONS TO HEART AND AS
IT'S BEEN DESCRIBED HE'S
PRIORITIZED- ALL OF THESE
ISSUES IN WAYS THAT EMPHASIZE
COLLABORATION COMPASSION
JUSTICE AND EQUITY I KNOW HE'LL
TAKE THE SAME APPROACH AS OUR
NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I'D
BE LOATH TO MENTION I'D BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT MENTION
THAT HE WOULD BE THE SECOND
ASIAN AMERICAN AFTER COMELEC
HARRIS IN THIS OFFICE SO HE'S
GOT BIG SHOES TO FILL. HIGHER
DRIVE VOTE ON THIS NOMINATION.
THANK YOU. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO INS
OF HIS I JUST WANT TO ADD SOME
MEMBERS OF ABOUT. MR BONTA IS
LEADERSHIP WHEN IT COMES TO.
INSURING RACIAL JUSTICE FOR
ENSURING THE VOICES OF- THOSE
SUBJECT TO HATE- ECONOMIC
JUSTICE SITE I'VE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH. ROB ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND I
WANT TO TESTIFIED TO HIS
READINESS TO SERVE WITH. THE
NECESSARY LEVELS OF A BOOK OF
AGGRESSION WHEN PEOPLE ARE
COMING DOWN ON CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS FROM OUTSIDE HIS ATTORNEY
GENERAL BASHIR IS DONE WITH
THIS LAST ADMINISTRATION. OR
CHARTING A NEW PATH I WITH THE
WILLING ADMINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON IN LEADERSHIP IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I TRULY SEE
OUR NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
CHARTING A NEW PATH- WHERE.
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ARE NOT SEEN AS AS OPPOSED BUT
AS PARTNERS IN AN EFFORT TO.
LAND CALIFORNIA AT THE
FOREFRONT AGAIN OF CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING HIS
NOMINATION AND HUMBLY AS FOR AS
I THOUGHT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
HEARING INCHING NINE. NUMBER
TEN WHICH ALLOWED TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I WANT
TO JUST POINT OUT THE ELOQUENT
AND THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS OF ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY.
THE SENATE I IN FACT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AT THIS MOMENT AS
WE RECALL THAT THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER. OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO ACTUALLY HAVE DIALOGUE AND
CONVERSATION IN A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY THAN WE TYPICALLY
ARE ABLE TO DO AS CALIFORNIA
VOTERS- WITH CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY. WE TAKE
THAT. THAT ARE RESPONSIBILITY
VERY SERIOUSLY- THE SENATE HAS
THE EXPERIENCE TO DO
CONFIRMATIONS- WE DO THAT AS A
REGULAR MATTER OF COURSE AND I
BELIEVE WE DO IT WITH US A
STATES LIKE. PRESENCE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND VERY- IF YOU
SERIOUS LEVEL OF RESPONSE. AS
EVIDENCED I THINK BY THE
INCREDIBLY RESPECTFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES NOT JUST ON ONE SIDE
OF THE AISLE BUT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE. MADE TODAY
AND YESTERDAY DURING THE
CONFIRMATION- TO SEND THIS
NOMINATION TO THE FLOOR HERE
TODAY AND MY A COLLEAGUE IN THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FROM A LAGOON IN A
GAL- REALLY I THINK ALONG WITH
THE COMMENTS TODAY. REFLECT THE
APPROACH THAT WE HAVE TAKEN.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE FEEL THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
DIALOGUE IN A WAY WITH A
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER- THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO IN THE
PAST AND SO. I THINK NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED TO FIND WAYS
TO WORK TOGETHER FOR THE OOD
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND WHILE
THERE WERE TOUGH QUESTIONS AND
DIALOGUES AND CONVERSATIONS
THAT OCCURRED THIS WEEK. I
THINK THAT THE QUIET.
CONFIDENCE AND THOUGHTFULNESS
AND RESPECT. THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- BONTA BROUGHT TO. THE
COMMITTEE CHAMBER YESTERDAY
REFLECT WHAT WE WILL SEE GOING
FORWARD AND I WANNA I WANNA
EMPHASIZE THE COMMENTS PEOPLE
MADE ABOUT THE HISTORIC NATURE
OF THIS MOMENT AND AGAIN TO SAY
NOW MORE THAN EVER AGAIN REPEAT
MYSELF WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
WORK TOGETHER AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
BODY THE WORK IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ALL THE TIME AND
ATTENTION WE HAVE GIVEN TODAY
TO THIS. VERY IMPORTANT
APPOINTMENT MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
APPOINTMENT. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER HI
PORGES. BRADFORD HI CABRERA HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. NO DODD. HI
THE RAZA. FIVE EIGHT. FIVE
PLEASE I CAN. I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI J. NO KAMLAGER HI
LEHRER. I LAY. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ O MAN BY NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW ABOUT. NO HAN
HIGH COURT AND- HI ROTH- HI
RUBY. FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER
ONE I LIKE HOW SKI HI WIENER HI
WILK NOW. MEMSIC VERY PLEASED
THE OPTIMUM. BATES BORJA.
GROWTH ARE USED ENOUGH KNOWS
THE POINT IS. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVE TO. SENATE THIRD READING.
WHERE TO UP FOR FOLLOW ITEM FOR
NINE. SENATOR URGED BURKE OR
YOU PREFER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE. SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
ACT RELATING TO EVIDENCE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER PRESIDENT
BRIEFLY. CALIFORNIA HAS
ESTABLISHED A PROCESS ALONG
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WE DO IT THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
WHERE OUR GOVERNMENT HAS MADE A
DETERMINATION THAT WILL
INTERVENE ON THE BEHALF OF
VICTIMS OF DISCRIMINATION. WE
HAVE BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN
THAT REGARD FOR MANY YEARS AS
THIS AGENCY HAS PROTECTED THE
RIGHTS AND ITS POLICE POWER ON
BEHALF OF OUR CITIZENS. FOR
THESE ABUSES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES THE SAME THING
WITH THE EEOC. ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES WE FACE IS THAT WE
STAND IN THE POSITION WHERE THE
INDIVIDUALS THE REAL PARTY IN
INTEREST BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A CONFIDENTIAL
RELATIONSHIP. WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE FULLY PROTECTED
COOPERATE AS WE PROTECT THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS. THE OTHER DAY. I
HAVE THE CASE RIGHT HERE MISTER.
PRESIDENT ON. MARCH THIRTEENTH
THE COURT OF APPEALS IN THE
FOURTH APPELLATE DISTRICT RULED
IN THE WOODS CASE WOULD CASE
CONTRA A MAJOR DECISION
CONTRARY TO HOW WE DO BUSINESS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SAYING THAT THE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION THIS CASE EMAILS IS
NOT PROTECTED BETWEEN THE
AGENCY AND THE INDIVIDUAL. THE
COURT MADE A BAD DECISION THEY
WERE WRONG. WHAT THE COURT DID
AND I WANT TO READ MISTER.
PRESIDENT IN THE IN THE
DECISION. THEY BASICALLY SAID
THAT OUR DEFERENCE TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S PARTICULARLY
NECESSARY WHEN WE'RE CALLED ON
TO INTERPRET THE CRITIQUE
PRIVATE PROVISION. BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DETERMINED THAT
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE TO BE
AVAILABLE ONLY AS DEFINED BY
STATUTE. SO WERE CAUGHT IN THIS
VORTEX OF HOW THE LAWS TO BE
INTERPRETED HAND SO THE COURT
BASICALLY INVITED US. TO STAND
AND TO FURTHER DEFINE RETURNING
CLIENT PRIVILEGES SO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL COULD
SHARE CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
WITH THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
GOVERNMENT HOLDS AT PRIVILEGE.
WE ARE TODAY IN THIS MEASURE
TAKING UP THAT INVITATION BY
THE COURT OF APPEALS FOR THE
PALETTE DISTRICT DIVISION ONE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. UNION SEEING NINE
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM. FORTY NINE. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER. HI FORGES NO BRADFORD HI
ABOUT OTHER HI CORTESE HI DALLY
NO DODD HI TERRAZZO HI EGGMAN.
HI GLAZER. NO GUNS ALL HI
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG HI WITH HI
HER TADO. HI JONES NO CAMERAS.
HI THERE. I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
KNEELED. NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
HAN HI. FORTY SORRY I ROTH. HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI I'M- HI
WHITE HOUSE HI WIENER I WILK.
FROM CERTAIN THIRD PLEASED THAT
SOME MEMBERS. ALLEN BATES NO.
WILK NO. VICE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE IS
APPROVED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX. SENATOR OF A
TROUT ARE YOU PREPARED FOR FILE
ITEM. FORTY SIX. BRANCH
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE%
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
FIVE BY SENATOR HER TADO
RELATIVE TO ADULT EDUCATION
CENTER TAL. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT S. C. R. TWENTY FIVE
WHICH PROCLAIMS APRIL
EIGHTEENTH TO APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH ADULT EDUCATION WEEK S.
YOUR TWENTY FIVE RECOGNIZE THE
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
CLASSIFIED STAFF AND STUDENTS
OF ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
ADULT EDUCATION SCHOOLS PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO FINISH SCHOOL
LEARN ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE CONTINUE THE PATH TO
THE UNITED STATES CITIZENSHIP
AS WELL AS COMPLETE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THE IMPACT THAT THE ADULT
EDUCATION HAS ON STUDENT LIVES
OUR COMMUNITIES FAMILIES AND
THE ECONOMY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS INVALUABLE FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. KERN AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER. HI GORGEOUS HI
BRADFORD HI CUT BY ADAM HI E.
DALLY HI DODD. I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH I HERTZBERG HI WITH. HI
TADO I JOAN I CAN'T. HI LAYERED
HI LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ I MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF VOGUE HI
PAM HI PORANTINO. HI ROSS. HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER HI NUMBER HI
WHAT. HI WIENER AYE WILK HI.
SURGERY PLEASE CALL UPS MEMBER.
CORTESE HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE. NUMBER
WERE MOVING ON TO THE CONCERN
CALENDAR. IS THERE ANY ITEMS.
MEMBERS WHICH TO HAVE RE FROM
CONSENT. INSANE NINE MADAM
CIRCUIT PLEASE RE TO CONSENT.
SENATE BILLS. TO THIRTY THREE
FOUR FIFTY FOUR SEVEN SIXTY TWO
ELEVEN FOUR NINETY EIGHT FOR
SIXTY THREE TO EIGHTEEN TO
SEVENTY THREE TO SEVENTY FOUR
TO NINETY TWO THREE FORTY SEVEN
THREE FIFTY TO THREE FIFTY
THREE FOR A ONE FIVE SIXTY FOUR.
SIX FORTY SEVEN SIX SEVENTY
THREE SEVEN OH THREE SEVEN
THIRTEEN AND SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU MA'AM
SIR TERRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM NINETY ONE. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA HI AT. HI BATES I
BAKER. HI BORJA. I BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI CORTESE HI DALY. I
DODD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HUESO. HI HER TADO
HI JOE. I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ.
I MILLION. I KNEW. HI NIELSEN I
A CHIRLA BOTH I PAN HI FOUR TO.
HI ROB. I RUBIO I. HI I'M BURKE
I REQUEST ON WIENER. THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SEND CALENDAR.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
pRESOLUTIONS CENTER MELENDEZ
YEAH THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AS SIERRA FIVE FROM
THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
THAT WE MAY HAVE A FULL AND
BIGGER IS DEBATE ABOUT THE
CONTINUED MERITS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF EMERGENCY.
CURRENTLY EVERY CALIFORNIANS
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN CAN
GET A COVERT VACCINE IF THEY
WANT TO ONE MOREOVER GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ANNOUNCED THAT ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH THE STATE WILL FULLY
REOPEN AND IT HAS BEEN FOUR
HUNDRED DAYS SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR COVERED AND SHUT DOWN THE
STATE CENSUS DECLARATION AROSE
AS LEGISLATORS HAVE BEEN
GREATLY DIMINISHED IF THE
CRISIS IS INDEED OVER THEN
THERE IS NO LONGER A NEED FOR
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S UNILATERAL FORTY
SENATORS IT IS BEEN FOUR
HUNDRED DAYS THE POWER IS
DEEMED TO HAVE BEEN TEMPORARY
HAVE NOW LASTED OVER A YEAR NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE SHOULD HEED
THE ALLEY IS ADVICE AND
JEALOUSLY GUARD OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN
AUTHORITY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I ASK FOR YOUR YE VOTE. ON
THIS MOTION THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK SENATOR HEARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT JOE LEADER AND- FOR A
NO VOTE THANK YOU. CENTER MY IS
ASKING FOR U. S. VOTE SENATOR.
ASKING FOR A VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL ROLL. ALLEN NO
ARCHULETA RULE NO ATKINS. BATES
I BACKER. NO FORTUS HI BRADFORD
YOU KNOW. NO COURTESY NO DALLY
HI DODD. NO THE RAZA NO EGGMAN
NO GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO GROW
HI FIVE HERTZBERG. NO WAY SO.
NO TADO. JONES HI CAN. NO
LAYERED. NO LEYVA. NO NO NO. NO
MULLIN. I MAN NO NEWMAN NO NO.
HI A CHIRLA VOTE. NOW I'M BURKE
NO WAY CASKEY. NO WIENER NO
WILK HI. MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
NO. HURTADO NO. FIVE NINE KNOWS
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW FILLS NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING DOWN TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH IN
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT AND
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE MEETING AT TEN
FORTY IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR.
FORTY TWO OR THREE. K.
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WILL BE
MEETING AT TEN FORTY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ALL THREE. OKAY
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OUR JOURNEY IN MEMORIES DO WE
HAVE A TURN MEMBERS. CENTER
PORTANTINO ARE YOU PREPARED. IS
THERE ARE TO LET ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR JOURNEY
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ERNIE PEREZ HE TO
MEN'S SALAS AND HONORED AND
RECOGNIZED NATIVE AMERICAN
CHIEF AND HIS WIFE VIRGINIA
ROSE MARIETTA SALAS. CHIEF
SALAS WAS A LONG TIME SPIRITUAL
LEADER. AND CHIEF FOR THE
DOUBLE YELLOW BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS QUICHE NATION. VIRGINIA
WAS A DEVOTED WIFE FOR SEVENTY
YEARS. THEY PASSED WITHIN ONE
WEEK OF EACH OTHER EARLIER THIS
YEAR. TOGETHER THEY RAISED A
WONDERFUL FAMILY INCLUDING FIVE
CHILDREN NINE GRANDCHILDREN
EIGHT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND
ONE GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILD.
CHIEF SALAS PLAYED A VITAL ROLE
IN MAINTAINING HIS AT AT
CENTRAL HERITAGE AND WAS VERY
ACTIVE THROUGHOUT HIS
COMMUNITY. NOTABLY IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO CHIEF SALAS WAS ABLE
TO SUCCESSFULLY PROTECT SACRED
ANCESTRAL SPRING FROM A MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT AND OBTAIN
FEDERAL RECOGNITION FOR THE
SPRING LOCATED NEAR THE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS. VIRGINIA WAS
ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE PARTNER IN
EVERYTHING THEY DID ON BEHALF
OF THE TRIBE AND THE NATIVE
AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE REGION.
THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO THE APRIL
YOU KNOW BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS QUICHE NATION WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN CHIEF SALAS
QUEST WHICH TO BRING ALL NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES TOGETHER. SO WE
AS AMERICANS COULD RECOGNIZE
OUR SERVICE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXTENSIVE HISTORY TO THIS
COUNTRY. CHIEF SALAS AND HIS
WIFE VIRGINIA WILL BE EXTREMELY
MISS AND FOR THESE REASONS I
ASKED TO JOIN IN THEIR MEMORY.
I THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU
CENTER PLEASE BRING THE NAME
FOR IT BOTH THE NAME TOWARD SO
CAN BE PROPERLY MORE A LARGE-
NEXT WERE MOVING ON TO THE
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR HIS
ADJOURNMENT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. ON MONDAY. THIS
COUNTRY LOST AN EXTRAORDINARY.
PUBLIC SERVANT VICE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT FITS MONDLI DIED IT'S
NINETY THREE. WE KNOW IS
HISTORY IS THE MINNESOTA
ATTORNEY GENERAL. SENATOR FROM
MINNESOTA VICE PRESIDENT TO
CARTER. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WHEN HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT I'D
STATES YOU CHOSE GERALDINE
FERRARO. AS HIS RUNNING MATE.
MAKING HISTORY MEDONTE
SERVICING **** JAPAN AND IN HIS
INIMITABLE STYLE BECAME A
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA HUBERT HUMPHREY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC POLICY. INGEST
DAY THE DAY BEFORE HE DIED ON
MONDAY. HIT A TELEPHONE
CONVERSATION WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT CARTER FORMER
PRESIDENT CLINTON. CURRENT VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS AND
PRESIDENTIAL WIDEN. SENATOR
KLOBUCHAR'S BOTHA. THE JURY
ABOUT HIM. AND TALKED ABOUT HIS
CHARACTER SHE WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT NINETEEN EIGHTY AND
VICE IN HIS LAST YEAR OF OFFICE
AS VICE PRESIDENT. AND TLKED
ABOUT HIS NATURE THE WORD TO
USE WHICH RESONATES WITH ME
YOUR HUMBLENESS. AND GOOD HUMOR
FIREEYE'S BOTH TO RECOGNIZE AND
RESPECT HIS EXTRAORDINARY
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS COUNTRY IN
SO MANY WAYS THAT WERE DONE
QUIETLY WITHOUT FANFARE PRESS
CONFERENCES BUT ALWAYS WITH
ELEGANCE AND GRACE. AND SOMEONE
WHO IS A YOUNG KID HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK FOR M. AS
IN VANCE MAN TRAVELING WITH
THEM ALL OVER THE PLACE. I
REMEMBER I WAS ORGANIZING A
PRECINCT WALK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT MONTANA IN
BILLINGS MONTANA FOR MAX
BAUCUS. WHO WAS THEN A
CONGRESSMAN RUNNING FOR UNITED
STATES SENATE. AND WE BOUGHT
THE VICE PRESIDENT TO WALK
PRECINCTS AND WHAT. I'D WORK
LIKE CRAZY TO MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE ARE TO BE HOME WE GOT TO
THE FIRST DOOR WHO IS NOBODY.
WE GOT TO THE SECOND ORDER WAS
THE OVER THE HE PULLED ME ASIDE
SAYS. THERE BETTER BE SOMEBODY
IF THE THIRD DOOR AND THERE
WAS. THE TURDIDAE SMILE THAT HE
WAS JUST JOKING WITH ME IT IS A
KID YOU KNOW YOU WANNA. MELT
WHEN A GUY LIKE THAT DOES THAT
TO YOU TO TRY TO GET IT RIGHT.
BUT HE WAS JUST ALWAYS GRACIOUS
I SAW THAT SENSE OF HUMOR SO
OFTEN I WAS THERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO ORGANIZING THE TRIP
WHEN HARVEY MILK KILLED AND-
GEORGE MOSCONI GOT KILLED HE
SHOWED UP. TO EULOGIZE AND PAY
RESPECT HIM TO REACH OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY IN AN UNBELIEVABLE.
WAY HE HAD THIS MANNER ABOUT
HIM. BUT I WAS ABLE TO WIN.
FIRSTHAND AS A YOUNG KID- I WAS
THERE WHEN PRESIDENT. I WAS
THERE WHEN PRESIDENT CARTER WAS
COSTS GOING SOME PLACE IN THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST I CAN'T
REMEMBER WE GOT A CALL OVER THE
WALKIE TALKIES WE HAD IN THOSE
DAYS FROM THE WALK OFFICE THE
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATION
AGENCY AND SAYS. THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE DELAYED AN HOUR THERE'S
BEEN A HOSTAGE TAKING IN AROUND
FOURTEEN FORTY DAYS LATER
BUDGET BUT MONDALE CAME IN DID
THE DID THE WORK. WITH KINDNESS
AND GRAYSON AND JUST YOU KNOW
WE IN THE SENATE OFTEN DON'T
DEAL. DIRECTLY WITH PEOPLE LIKE
HIM BUT I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT HE PROVIDED
GUIDANCE. AS AN EXAMPLE OF
BEING A PUBLIC SERVANT. WHO
ALWAYS WORKED HARD. WHO NEVER
FORGOT- THE WORKING FOLKS. WHO
WHO ARE WE SHOWED UP. AND WAS
YOU KNOW WE ALL SEE THIS OFTEN
IN OUR JOBS WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
WE MEET. AND THEY LOOK GOOD
PUBLICLY BUT PRIVATELY BEHIND
THE SCENES THEY'RE NOT THAT
KIND AND GRACIOUS. IT IS WHAT
SENATOR KLOBUCHAR SAID. HE HAD
HUMILITY HUMBLENESS. AND GOOD
HUMOR I ASKED WE JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
FRITZ MONDALE. THANK YOU A FINE
EXAMPLE OF PUBLIC SERVICE LET'S
BRING THE NAME FOR IT SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR PORTANTINO ARE YOU
PREPARED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF JOANNE MIND
MONTGOMERY AT. AWESOME PERSON
AND A VERY CLOSE FRIEND WHO
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
FOURTEENTHFROM HEART FAILURE.
JOANNE WAS BORN N WEST
FRANKFORT ILLINOIS AND SPENT
HER EARLY LIFE IN ARIZONA I
LIVING IN ARIZONA SHE RECEIVED
HER BA FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA AND JOINED KAPPA KAPPA.
KAPPA KAPPA GAMMA SORORITY SHE
WAS AN ACTIVE ALARM THAT UNTIL
THE PAST UNTIL HER PASSING SOON
AFTER GRADUATING SHE MOVED TO
MONROVIA WITH HER HUSBAND
DONALD AND RAISED THEIR TWO
CHILDREN CYNTHIA AND ANDREW.
JOANNE WAS A BELOVED EDUCATOR
AND SPENT THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER AFTER
RETIREMENT JOANNE WAS ELECTED
TO SERVE ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE CITRUS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. IN THAT ROLE
SHE CONTINUED HER GREAT LOVE
FOR EDUCATION SERVING FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS SHE LOVED ART
HISTORY BRIDGE AND TRAVEL BUT
MOST OF ALL SHE CHERISHED HER
GRANDCHILDREN AND HER GREAT
CHAIR GRANDCHILDREN. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER BROTHER ED AND
HIS WIFE HER CHILDREN CINDY AND
ANDREW ALONG WITH. HIS WIFE
GRANDCHILDREN KATIE MARIE ALONG
WITH HER HUSBAND MOISES TAYLOR
AND HIS WIFE AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN GRACIE OLIVER AND
MEET. ME LIKE MILLIE JO CYNTHIA
ANOTHER GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
WENT ON TO BE A NOTED EDUCATOR
LIKE HER MOM AND A PRINCIPAL
RETIRED RECENTLY AS THE
PRINCIPAL IN THE GLENDALE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
COMMANDS POSITIVE INFLUENCE ON
OUR CHILDREN WILL BE FELT AND
RIPPLE FOR DECADES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO RETURN AND
HER WONDERFUL MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR PLEASE BRING THE NAME
FORTS. OR COULD BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER BATES THE
DEATHS CLAY. MISTER PRESIDENT
OF THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM AND EVERYONE
HAVE A GREAT GREAT WEEKEND.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE SENATE
WILL BE A RACE RECESSED UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM THANK YOU.